okay
please join with me in a pledge to our
flag I pledge allegiance to the flag of
foreign
like to open the executive session
on
with resources Recreation development
committee and the first and only bill
will be we will be hearing
is SB
11 in the chair recognizes uh
representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
the amendment 2023 excuse me for to for
the bill move the bill oh thank you okay
I'd like to move on to pass on the bill
and I'll just speak to that buff
representative harp I will second that
motion
all right now representative McHugh for
an amendment to the Bill thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move Amendment
2023-1597h
okay representative harb yes I will
second the motion to amend
um representative of uh Mercure would
you like to speak to your motion yes
please thank you Mr chairman the
amendment that I think everybody got a
fresh copy of today is unchanged since
we last spoke about it it's two zero two
three one five nine seven eight it's the
amendment to Senate Bill 11 that we had
a lot of discussion about
um the last time we met and we had a
little straw poll on uh this is the
amendment supported by the the division
supported by the prime sponsor uh that
takes virtually all of the prime
sponsors language puts it into the right
parts of the RSA
and uh calls for
um the consultation with descendants and
descendant Community prior to excavation
and exploration of any historical or
unmarked African-American or other newly
discovered Graves essentially uh
preserves current practice into statute
as I believe representative wrong points
out we want to make sure that if any
changes in the Staffing
occurs that we preserve what we all
believe to be good current practice so
if anything like what happened in I
believe Portsmouth any
uncovered African-American Graves or
other Graves that we continue to have
that good practice so we want to
preserve what's a very good bill brought
forth by the sponsors so we take this
language and codify it and that's what
this amendment does so I asked for the
continued bipartisan support it was
bipartisan sponsor ship from the Senate
and I look back through send a testimony
and our testimony and I didn't find
anybody who actually came out
specifically against some form of
passing the bill so that's what this
does it gets us to a good passage so
thanks thank my colleagues for
supporting the amendment and eventually
an otpa on this amendment
okay thank you uh representative power
would you like to speak to your second I
will be sure uh after testimony of Mr
Wilson and listening to the prime
sponsor I think this is an appropriate
Amendment and I fully support it and the
bill is amended thank you
thank you is there any uh
anyone who wishes to speak to the
amendment
seeing none on the on the amendment
as uh
1597 H the clerk please call the roll
yes
representative harp yes
representative Gould
yes
representative Horgan yes
clickbust yes representative Healy yes
uh representative uh Aaron yes
representative McHugh yes
representative Don yes
uh representative Vale yes
representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson I'm
representative Horrigan with the extra
Oregon from Durham I'm searching for
Simpsons one vote Yes okay
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative renzullo yes okay
unanimously passed
okay okay
and then and pardon me for the uh for
being remiss and uh
I'm not introducing the uh the
substitutes
representative represent
yeah uh on on
ought to pass
as amended
we do like to speak on ought to pass as
amended chair representation
representative
thank you thank you Mr chairman um thank
you to my colleagues for supporting the
ought to pass as amended
representative
I have no further comments thank you Mr
chair
well does anyone wish to speak to them
seeing none
well the court please call the rule
thank you um representative herb yes
representative Gould yes representative
Horgan yes the clerk votes yes
representative Healy yes representative
Aaron
yes
representative McHugh
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative wrong yes
uh representative Kelly yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative yes
unanimously passed
move consent
uh uh consent
yes we're consent
okay any uh any more any other business
seeing none
I will adjourn the hearing
Executives during the adjourn the
executive session
now we have to wait here for another two
hours in order to collect our mileage so
I'm only kidding
Mr chairman
were there some bills from our committee
that are rumored or known to be off
consent
yes there are there are but we don't
have a hearing to open on those bills so
I recommend that we meet in our
individual caucuses and then the chair
and I will meet if that's okay with the